dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I hear subsurface
scattering means that a portion of light
that hits a translucent material does
not bounce back from the surface but
penetrates it in scatters many many
times inside the material now if you
have a keen eye you'll recognize that
there are a lot of materials in real
life that have subsurface scattering
many don't know but our skin is a great
example of that and so is marble milk
wax plant leaves apple and many others
if you would like to hear a bit more
about subsurface scattering check the
second part of the video that you see
recommended in the corner of this window
or just click it in the description box
below subsurface scattering looks
unbelievably beautiful but at the same
time it is a very expensive because we
have to simulate up to thousands and
thousands of scattering events for every
ray of light it really takes forever and
if you'd like to tweak your material
settings just a bit because the result
is not a hundred percent up to your
taste you have to recreate or what
graphics people like to say we render
these images it's not really a
convenient workflow this piece of work
offers a great solution where you have
to wait a bit longer than you would wait
for one image but only once because it
runs a generalized light simulation and
after that whatever changes you apply to
your materials you will see immediately
you can also paint the reflectance
properties of this material that we call
albedo x' and get results with full
subsurface scattering immediately
you
here's another interactive editing
workflow where you get results
instantaneously and the result with this
technique is indistinguishable from the
real deal which would be rendering this
result image every time some adjustment
is made
with this technique you can really
create the materials you thought up in a
fraction of the time of the classical
workflow
you
spectacular work thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time